this is the 3D print of The Culinary
tablet the three recipes that we're
cooking today are derived from they come
from the Babylonian culinary recipes
that are in the Yale Babylonian
collection
almost 4 000 years old these are the
oldest recipes ever found
they asked me if I had the recipes but I
should have been like well yeah I do I
have the recipes right here guys are you
ready
[Music]
we have chosen three recipes that come
from one tablet and today will be the
first time that we're trying the
unwinding recipe that's the vegetarian
one it's it's really unclear why it's
called unwinding the word in the
beginning of the recipe can have some
different interpretations and one of
them is similar to unwinding a knot and
so it's thought that maybe this recipe
is something that you would create to
enjoy and sort of relax oh my God that's
so hot it's a vegetarian stew based on
leek and onion there doesn't seem to be
any particular reason for this name we
honestly we don't know
[Music]
one of the recipes tuhi has red beaks
kind of a proto-burst this is leaning
tower of pizza it has a really nice sort
of earthy taste not something that I
would have ever imagined would be in
Babylonian cooking foreign
[Music]
is milk based with some lamb I don't
like that one
honestly during the process of cooking I
did not think that it looked very
appetizing really I just thought I'm not
even going to taste this I didn't like
that one as much because the lamb is at
the Forefront of the flavor instead of
the the variety of flavors in the tuhi
but after I had cooked and simmered we
saw a bit of thickened and I don't know
it's just transformed into something
that was sophisticated lots of different
flavors surprisingly good
foreign
[Music]
cooking and eating and using that our
senses is such a basic human experience
and I think it gives it everything like
a profound sense of deep history to
taste the flavors that were prominent
then and popular then and to think the
tools that were aided by make this so
much easier than it was for for them you
feel closer to the the culture and the
people that's one of the reasons that we
really went into this project maybe not
entirely is they would have prepared it
maybe our ingredients taste a little bit
different that's okay I like that I like
it better than the lambra but still
approximating something that nobody has
tasted for almost 4 000 years
[Music]
thank you